thanks to puget systems
for sponsoring today's episode stick
around to the end to find out why
they're the best computers
ever hey guys welcome back to vfx artist
react we are on bollywood
number five today man bollywood's great
it's crazy it really is it's
no rules there's no limits it's
practically live action anime
and every single time i go through these
clips i'm like why aren't american films
this cool
americans are too afraid yeah i'm afraid
too afraid you know indian
cinema is is unashamed of who they are
what are you doing
brent has been afraid that since he's a
little further behind us here
he's worried he looks a little small on
camera so today we're trying out a new
booster seat
to make him look like one of the big
boys
let's flip on into some clips here guys
get off the toilet
wipe those cheeks and let's get started
so this movie is basically about like a
hot assassin
and his hot girlfriend she's escaping in
the water we're gonna get her
you see those muzzle flashes of course
here's my favorite part
here we go it's all about the reveals
how cool can you look
while being revealed this guy's hitting
all the marks so he's just got a water
jet pack i guess so he's just flying on
this thing
like a beautiful dolphin dude this shot
right here he's like literally just
dolphining along
so you're thinking how does this guy do
this how does he do these sweet stunts
on his like water jet pack he seems to
defy physics right
that's another like baseline standard
for
these movies how do you think they did
that they did it for real
yeah they're rotoing stuff out yes
because there's a tube that's connected
in the water there's a
there's a complete apparatus and tube
that is the source of the water because
there's a base
that's under water that basically
sucking the water up
and propelling it down through his feet
i guess from a style standpoint they're
like that's not cool enough
let's just pretend like he's just
generating water out of nothing just
generating water out of his feet i
didn't even realize that that was
painted out you're totally right it's
not there
so actually that's not that hard of a
paint out though honestly because it's
like
practically the same as painting out a
wire it is it is and and the thing that
is being replaced with it is just more
of that frothy
uh foam and water splashing it's like
this is fairly doable what makes this
hard is that all of those elements that
are being painted back in are all moving
and it all has to kind of like
seamlessly work over the course of
several seconds rather than just as a
still frame that's certainly a challenge
yeah
also painting out those mountains and
adding the water splashes back
in over the sky seems like a pretty
tough challenge too
well those water splashes look like they
could be pulled from a luma mat look at
how much brighter they are from the
water and the sky
you can use the brightness of an image
to separate it from
the rest of it you basically just make a
black and white image that's just
cranked full of contrast and use that as
your aluminum mat
to pull the splashes of the water away
from the background as opposed to say
like rotoscoping each one of those
little water droplets
this is kind of a way to just kind of
isolate all the water droplets without
having to actually do any rotoscoping
[Music]
are we not even gonna are we not gonna
talk about these muzzle flashes
i'm done talking about muzzle flashes
all muscle flashes suck
almost all most bollywood muzzle flashes
are lackluster subpar nephew
effects basically real talk if you are a
director
in india and you're making a film like
this and you need some muzzle flashes
reach out to us because i think we could
lend a hand
[Applause]
this is pure original filmmaking
the biggest bro
look at this look at their hands dude
dude that's so good that's why that's
why bollywood is so good
it's moments like that
[Music]
are those the actual actors are they
stuntmen that's probably a head replace
it's got to be
so actually the head replacement they're
doing that almost all the time here head
replacements there
this is head replacement city yeah i see
how they're doing that so here we go so
these are some head replacements
see the guy in the foreground here on
the motorcycle yeah i'm pretty sure we
got a head replacement going up on him
there
that motorcycle yeah the back motorcycle
looks compton
i think the motorcycle isn't actually
there look at the shadow look at the
contact shadow
watch how smoothly the motorcycles are
going down the stairs i don't
i'm not seeing that like jitter or that
bump that you'd normally see from
a motorcycle you know what you're
totally right it's the shadow it's all
about that shadow but the end result
is very good it's hard to even notice
anything because you're just so sucked
up into the action of the moment
[Music]
green screen yeah so that jumping off
the bridge was obviously a compton
element he probably just jumped off of
something on a stage they put them in
the shot
you can tell because the lighting
doesn't totally match yeah it's like
studio
kind of lighting okay well here's the
thing did they have anyone actually do
this
or is this all in a studio for the
elements i feel like it'd be all in
studio like that'd be such a big deal to
shut that bridge down and do a giant
stunt like that
like the shot looking down of him when
you don't see his face looks good that
the snap
yeah that snap of him like actually
hitting and making the rope taut like
and then flying sideways that's the best
looking part of this entire sequence
and even that right here when he's like
too small to even make out who
that is i think that's a real person i
think a person actually jumped into the
water here
that is not real that is definitely a
jpeg
that's a freaking png so sam last time
decided it would be a great idea
to just go ahead and tell everyone to
unsubscribe and hit the report button
hit unsubscribe dislike the video flag
others comments well that backfired
yeah so uh we got a strike on our
channel here and we might actually have
to shut down
so the only way to fix that is if you
all subscribe yeah you're gonna have to
subscribe i hate to say it
it's out of necessity now
wait what movie is this this is padmavat
this is a little this is just a little
fun fact for y'all there's a little
dance number here tell me what's wrong
with
tell me is there anything off what's
iffy about this i'm assuming nothing's
wrong with this clint
something is being altered in this scene
with the main dancer here i haven't
detected anything yet
but does she not actually have that nose
ring nah i know this they painted out a
mustache
you're cool you're getting closer oh
really you're getting closer you're
getting closer
something's being covered up this is a
cover-up there's a lot of controversy
about this one
the midriff the mid-rip was too risque
the midriff was
too much to handle i think it was too
saucy they banned it because it was too
saucy
leave the skin revealed outrage covered
up outrage no matter what
outrage so they they concealed it dude
they had to vfx that whole side
what the side body i i see it now i i
can see how they uh they tracked in the
cloth
around the area there but dude look at
all this work all this work that goes
into just covering up that tiny little
thing right
i mean well they did a great job yeah i
couldn't tell i was staring at it and i
couldn't tell
dude we're getting in we're getting into
some bollywood drama here
what do you guys think midriff or no
midriff leave a comment down below
uppercase letter i is the name of this
movie
it's a hollywood film this movie has
like three plots in one
there's a lot going on and it's got some
gold
let's put it on and have a good time
how are they gripping each other are
they not just super slippery
i know this is the most oily bronze
fight
[Music]
is he gonna throw them or spin them
oh
yeah where are the visual effects though
there's no there's no official
this is a prank i guess although let me
throw a
a thought here where do you hide a wire
on a buff dude
their their harness would have to be
under their what do you call the the
thong what is that the speedo speedo
thank you
this move right here where are you
hiding those wires dude
in the briefs either that or he's
wearing a harness and there's like a lot
of skin being painted on oh yeah
actually no look at how smooth his
abdomen and sides are here see how it's
like a hot dog
oh yeah okay so i think he's wearing a
harness and they're just painting his
skin none
vfx artists react justified let's move
on to the next thing we're done
wait what it's a person oh my god he's
having sex with a motorcycle
oh my god it's a transformer effect
isn't that crazy because the upside down
woman's face there looking at the camera
is just really
[Music]
unsettling dude yeah
those transformation shots are actually
pretty great like they're really smooth
and like the transition with the like
the real actress coming out of this
stuff
just wait what's this
oh what the hell
what the hell in the gym
[Music]
oh no no no no
no no no hold on what the [ __ ] did we
just watch
is this a motion control i think they
actually shot the footage first
and then tracked that to get the motion
data out of that so that they can
actually have
a controlled camera shooting the exact
same camera move
of him she's not real at all that is a
3d printer at the end here when he's
about to kiss her
no still still cg
watch this watch this little squirt of
oil oh gross
are there sparks on the ground from her
butt grinding on the
pavement this filmmaking is top notch
seriously this is this is kollywood
right here
every time we do one of these episodes
it gets more difficult to top so
we need your help please leave some
movies and some scenes in the comments
below
give them the thumbs up we take a look
at them they actually help us pull the
clips for
the next episodes
just the preface the scene we're about
to watch is from the same movie
hold on wait wait wait wait wait wait oh
it's petrol
probably he's gonna light him on fire i
don't think that's petrol i think it's
some sweet sauce
[Music]
he's like what is one pea gonna do yeah
oh my god
holy crap suddenly the effects got super
advanced
very quickly houdini sims yeah
dude the drippy bees yeah yeah no that
was what i was saying that that foot
shot is like it's interacting with the
ground it's dripping off of them that's
so well done
yeah it's beyond my wildest dreams
how do you think they did this maybe
they tracked
his model and then put these all over
him basically they're able to create a
3d model of him track to him as he's
moving
and they're able to assign all like
thousands of bees
with their own special animation to
adhere to the surface of him
interacting with each other without you
know clipping and stuff like that that's
a really good vfx that's really good vfx
um but there's one shot here where it's
an extreme close-up of the bee going
into his nose
what a render i know what a render
that almost looks real to me
specifically how he closes his eyes
and you see like everything perfectly
deform you guys are right it looks so
real
i don't get it oh i know it i figured it
out i figured it out
lay down on us so it's an extreme zoom
lens from one angle
but then it cuts to a close-up and
that's how they're getting all that
animation data from his lips moving
around and his cheeks moving around
and so they're able to track that and
actually have that influence the 3d
around it so it the difference there is
that that second shot is a real
photographic plate of the actor
but the bees are still cg these are some
pretty advanced bfx right here
this is crazy bfx by the way this is
still the same movie from like
five minutes ago by the way
guys i've traveled across the space time
continuum once again to tell you about
today's sponsor puget systems now these
guys
are super super important to everything
that we do here and i know that you guys
normally don't believe the things that i
have to say so i brought in my friend
sam
to help give you an artist's touch these
guys have been building computers for
hundreds
of years it's a tradition passed down
from generation
to generation so every single computer
we have in our studio
at this point is a puget except for one
and it sucks but forget that computer
the point is though the way they work is
they take whatever you want to
accomplish with this machine whether
you're going to be doing
3d rendering if you're going to do video
editing if you're going to be doing like
audio
design or something like that and they
will build that specs for a computer
that is
tailor made to match those tasks and
it's really cool
not to mention every single computer
they build they
test the crap out of them and make sure
they work perfectly before they even
arrive
at your doorstep so you know you can
just plug it in turn it on and get going
they document all the bios settings so
that if you ever have a problem with
your system
you call them up they know exactly
what's in your pc and exactly how it's
set
so they can fix it right there with you
on the phone consider this
puget also has built computers for nasa
so that's all that really matters and i
heard they also built computers for that
one ufo program that's uh that's
happening right now too
but i think that's top secret maybe i
can't remember
so if you guys are interested there's a
link in the description below or
head on over to pugetsystems.com they
make all the videos that you see here
possible
head on over there right now like what's
what's the problem just click the link
check it out bollywood episodes are
always incredibly fun to do
and we're gonna do more so thank you for
watching this episode and stay tuned for
the next one i'm not sure what next week
will be
but we got another bollywood episode in
the works so stay tuned
hopefully my hair hasn't been too
distracting this episode